The Office for National Statistics said
today that average weekly earnings
during the period rose by 2.8 percent
including and excluding bonuses that was
the strongest growth since the summer of
2015 consumer price inflation in
February was 2.7 percent meaning that
real wages rose by 0.1 percent that's
the first time since February last year
and the ONS also revealed that the
unemployment rate fell during the period
to just 4.2 percent which was the lowest
since May 1975 or with me to discuss
this
it's the economist Vicky price making
very good to see you so do you think
this marks the end of the squeeze and
real wages well the first thing to say
is that it's good news because of course
we've had such a long period of falling
real disposable incomes which of course
has had huge impact on people's
willingness to go and spend yes I think
what is happening right now of course is
that the pound has strengthened against
the dollar at any rate against which so
many of the things that were import up
priced and that has helped inflation
rate which is really good news wages are
creeping up mainly because of shortages
that are already quite prevalent in a
number of sectors and that's good news
too because it means that finally
certainly if we look ahead in the next
few months there would be hopefully
something more substantial there in
terms of the game that workers will get
in terms of real wages so I think yes I
think the the unless there is any
serious change in terms of the the
inflation rate caused by any drop now in
the pound which is unlikely we are
probably beginning to see a slight
improvement happening in the next few
months not huge but that's good news I
mean 4.2 percent unemployment that was
probably the standout feature of these
numbers today wasn't it something
shouldn't we be seeing higher wages
inflation in the light of that sort of
level of jobless rate I think we
probably should but if you look at what
is happening in various sectors remember
quite a lot of the increases in jobs
that have taken place have been in quite
low wage areas they've been in the gig
economy they have been in places where
actually average wages are quite low
themselves lots of part-time work taking
place which again is not particularly
highly valued so what you're seeing is
that in a number of cases of course
where there are serious profit issues
such as in the retail sector there is
really no ability or no willingness to
give extra
increases in wages and I think that's
what's keeping them down despite the
fact that it's clearly the Shorter's in
so many areas right now what was
encouraging about these numbers though
is that there are genuine full-time jobs
being created that is where the bulk of
job creation is coming through it isn't
just part-time work it isn't just gig
work is it no no this is absolute true
but nevertheless what you've seen you've
seen for quite some time now is that
those types of jobs that are around the
gig economy jobs and so on are setting
some sort of basis for what people are
getting paid per hour and of course what
we're going to be seeing increasingly is
the impact of the increasing minimum
wage which is going to be influencing
wages over the next few months I think
that's quite significant I think what we
might see therefore is that people are
more willing to come in to the market
and and do more of that work because
participation rate interesting enough
went down so I think those low wages
generally have discouraged people from
coming in and moving from benefits and
coming into work does it follow though
that this is going to put more money in
people's pockets I mean another big
change that we've got coming through at
the moment is that people who are
automatically enrolled into pension
schemes are going to see a big increase
in their contributions as much which
eats into their take-home pay that's a
real issue and of course if interest
rates go up as they're likely to as well
so we're going to see some impact on
that on mortgages so many people have
mortgages which our interest only and
that's going to be a problem for them in
terms of keeping up their payments what
we're seeing already actually is that
the consumer is being much more cautious
they're not spending things on
non-essentials we've seen that happening
for example in the car sector in
addition of course to the problems for
because of diesel cars as well but we've
seen that very significantly showing
there and we've seen that it's mainly on
sort of food and and essential items
that people are spending their their
money on retail sales have suffered as a
result and what you've got actually out
of the latest data coming from visa
which is looking at how people are
spending you seeing a drop in spending a
significant drop in spending happening
month after month people are worried
about the future despite the fact that
employment is such a high level you just
put your finger on the major point that
does this mean that an interest rate
rise next month is nailed on I don't
really think there is any serious need
for increasing interest rates on the
other hand of course if you haven't got
something to bring back down it's going
to be a problem you take on of me so
down so I think we're probably going to
see that increase I think it's going to
be an issue for consumers if it carries
on hopefully that would be it for some
time other people seem to think that we
may get another one later on with
inflation coming down and we'll improve
a thing in the next few months unless
there is some serious crisis in the oil
market for example of war or whatever
may happen
Joe politically then I think that
actually the interest rate increases
will like you see this year going to be
very very modest well the oil price is
up some twenty four percent since the
beginning of October last year and of
course we've seen the lights of British
Gas raising prices already you're not
too concern that's going to feed through
to aggressive hikes in inflation I think
it will fit through to some increases
there's no doubt about that I'm not
expecting that we can see a real
substantial fall inflation but we can
see inflation which is comfortably
within the margin that doesn't require
the the governor of the Bank of England
to write a letter to the Chancellor of
the Exchequer so in other words it will
stay below 3% unless there is some
serious change in the markets and yes
you're absolutely right about the old
price it has been going up is still much
lower than it has been for example in
the previous years when we the when the
world was growing as fast as it is now
we would have been expecting actually to
have oil prices considerably higher and
we haven't seen that the reason why
their strength and now is not so much
because of world trade being so strong
as it has been which has helped the
economy it is really because of the
uncertainty in the Middle East